veteran left-hander tommy malone now 33
years old mike prosso steps in swung on
and miss 86 mile an hour fastball jose
martinez
and down on strikes goes jose martinez
you know yani torino is out there on the
mound for the tampa bay race faces
loaded two outs dj stewart
[Applause]
ground ball that's a fair ball over the
bag makes the play unassisted so here's
rent throw
and here's a runner on board and well
margot at the plate 2-2 pitch
got him swinging third strikeout for
tommy malone here's willy adams malone's
pitch
swinging a line drive base headed to
left field for willy adams so kevin
kiermeier at the plate
there's a liner into right going to drop
in front of santander
the bases are going to be loaded mike
cenino
popped him up
a lot of sun out there
and the orioles get the out this is
yandy diaz 2-2 pitch on the way
[Applause]
bounce to third palleka the second
it's pretty close over there but he got
him
it's brandon lau
down he goes strikeout number four for
tommy malone and he's got the strikeout
pitch working again the pitch it is it's
that change up right there and it's so
good he'll even throw at the
left-handers jose martinez one two and
he got him on strike so back-to-back
strikeouts from tommy malone and now
here comes renato nunez
and this one's hit the left field in
deep back goes the left fielder margot
looking up and it's gone
nunez has done it again
renato nunez on the first pitch from
yani torinos gives the orioles a
one-nothing lead
looks like that veteran kind of
cool and calm doesn't show a lot of
emotion on the hill
there's a sixth strikeout
mark go down
two down
jeremiah good numbers against malone
he throws it by him kiermeier down on
strikes tommy malone is struck out seven
hamza alberto coming up for the third
time
oh nice oh
nice pick up by braso throw to first got
him nicely done third to first right
there on a sharply hit ball by alberto
they'll put a star by that one for
bronzo
the catcher pedro severino
coming in he's there to make the catch
got that glove down there at the last
moment to grab that pop fly
and severino is the second out
that's it for yanni two outs into the
fifth jaylen beaks the new rave pitcher
iglesias will pinch hit for cisco
and the fastball lined into right
[Applause]
santander heads to the plate he's going
to be out
he's called out
you can understand why the orioles
wanted to take a look at it when you
look at that left hand but the good
thing for the rays the call went their
way yeah and in those two shots one of
them you could not see the runner's hand
right and then the other one you could
not see the tag it was yeah the the
angle was bad so i think you've got to
let it stand so he's out yep so that
will
retire the side under the sixth heading
the rays are down by a run brendan lau
leading off
so fly ball
back into center that's got some carry
to it might get out of here gone
home run by brandon lau
and just like that this game is tied on
the second home run of the year for lau
cedric mullen scuffling
drops a bunt down the first baseline
beaks can't handle it and mullins
reaches on the bun there you go that's
like he puts a little pressure on you
just pushes it right up the first base
line
left-handed pitcher always falls off
towards the third base side that's it
for jalen beats the left-hander is out
he'll give way to the right-hander chas
wrote there he goes
zanino fires it's high
and the orioles have the go-ahead run in
scoring position one for three for
alberto tonight 1-1 pitch
lined into right field that'll get him
in
down into the corner alberto around
second he's got a double
as mullen scores and the orioles go on
top 2-1
and that brings up renato nunez
bounced up the middle into center field
here comes the throw to the plate it's
up the line and the orioles take a 3-1
lead as alberto scores
on the base hit and good base running
as nunez moves up to second on the throw
so that'll take a two out hit to bring
him in galasias had a base hit and he's
only at bat he rips that one down the
left field line that'll get a run in
nunez can trot home iglesias
hobbling just a little bit as he rounds
first you can see that quad injury but
he didn't have to run hard there an rbi
double for jose iglesias
[Applause]
alaika
1-1 to valenca
hit well center field
kiermeier back on the track it's out of
here
pat valleca
he walked it off last night with a base
hit and now goes yard here to give the
orioles a 5-1 lead
how about a little bit of insurance
not a save opportunity if they brought
in another reliever but salsa it was a
safe opportunity when he started last
inning and he only threw nine pitches so
he's back out there let's pick up what
his third big league save if he can pull
this off they should do it
and the orioles
record a sweep of the rays
they went in here today 5-1